let's read this news
ah the world is falling apart yes from
timcast.com New Hampshire lawmakers
consider proposal to secede from the
United States amazing lawmakers in New
Hampshire are considering a
constitutional amendment to secede from
the rest of the country State Rep Mike
Sylvia filed a proposal that would make
New Hampshire its own nation-state
independent from DC quote there are
hundreds of examples of the federal
government overstepping its Authority
enough is enough we should put this
before the voters to decide Sylvia cited
the uscdc in prevention's eviction ban
Joe Biden's mandate which requires
federal workers to get the coveted
vaccine as examples of federal overreach
He also mentioned that New Hampshire
which has no state income tax is
obligated to pay federal income tax we
are a donor state that pays out more in
federal income taxes than we get back
seceding from the U.S would benefit
residents financially even if it does
mean a loss of federal funding the rep
noted
I want to make this point too about what
they're saying about seceding Joe Biden
now with the eviction moratorium he
bypassed the legislature with the
Supreme Court then saying we're shutting
that onto shutting it down it's illegal
and then him launching another
moratorium bypass the Supreme Court
now with this vaccine mandate he is once
again bypassing Congress we are a nation
at this point so what Jack Murphy was
saying the other day we're not a
republican anymore
laws are made when The Sovereign decrees
and then the plebs are are awarded a
chance if they are negatively impacted
to file a petition to the courts to
challenge this new law that's the way
this country has been run for the past
two years with all these lockdowns and
everything Cuomo killed people yeah
literally literally killed people in New
York city so when New Hampshire comes
out and says hey we're done with this
I'm like people need to realize this is
actually fairly serious and I'll tell
you something else something that had me
thinking
in Florida for instance where they ban I
think that I'm pretty sure they banned
the vaccine mandate yeah they did for
business establishments in West Virginia
we went to the city called I think it
was called Thurmond I'm not sure and
there was a train station that was
Federal property and there was a man
inside working for the Park Service
selling stuff
and if you wanted to go in you had to
wear a mask
now here's what my question if Florida
says you cannot have mass mandates which
they've been in schools I'm pretty sure
I'm not sure about for businesses they
banned it for schools for sure but what
about businesses I'm not sure so here's
here's my point if a federal building is
operating a business that sells
merchandise in a state that says you
cannot legally do this which means the
federal government is violating the law
in the state
can state troopers go in and I'm pretty
sure shut them down supersedes doesn't
it but there's no federal law mandating
masks no it's just a requirement it's
just a presidential decree so and truth
be told in Florida it is also a
Governor's decree so I think they'll
they it should absolutely go through the
legislature even if it's Rhonda census
or Abbott my question is there is no law
in the United States mandating masks so
these Federal buildings have no federal
law saying they should be wearing masks
it's just a policy I'll do it yeah so if
Florida does have a law or at the very
least if Biden says my mandate is sound
okay then then Rhonda Santa says my my
policy is sound
then what gives the federal government
actors the right to operate business in
the state and under violation of the
state's executive orders well have there
been any confrontations in Florida well
that's about it that's so interesting
because so much of this is about
enforcement right right I mean we
haven't seen police are not able to
enforce Mass mandates primarily the New
York City Police Department has refused
to do that kind of enforcement
uh New York City has this vaccine
vaccine mandate thing the New York City
Police Department is not enforcing it
it's like civilians it's Health
Inspectors it's random doofus hostesses
at restaurants saying excuse me like I
really need to see your vax card and ID
that's what's going on so
there hasn't been any violence about it
at this point because there hasn't been
any enforcement other than civilian on
civilian enforcement we saw that in
California when they were doing the
lockdowns it was Health Inspectors
versus like a business owner you know if
if you're in a restaurant in New York
you live in New York right I do if you
go in and I don't think you have
experience with this but I'm just
wondering what your thoughts are and
someone says can I see your Vex card and
you say no
what are they gonna do I don't know
because the cops won't enforce it you're
saying yeah the cops are not going to
enforce it I think I think then it's
just a question of like you standing
there saying no and the person there
going well sorry there was actually a
case today we ran a story about this in
the post-millennial it was this viral
video I don't know if you saw it yeah
yeah it was this like white restaurant
manager owner or whatever trying to kick
a black family for restaurants so
they're dark stuff so it's like systemic
racism for everything except this
apparently and you had the rest of the
patrons in the restaurant saying like oh
you need to show your vax card and he's
like we're not vaccinated and yeah he's
he was citing a religious exemption but
the reason I brought this up uh in
reference to New Hampshire because I
don't want to Veer too much off of sure
you're talking about secession from the
United States is that you know so I
think this family should move there in
this in the Civil War what kicked it off
was Fort Sumter when these states were
like yo we secede screw you and then
Union soldiers were still there and this
South Carolina I think South Carolina
was like yo get your troops out and they
were like No And they said then we're
going to force you out then fight broke
out and then a bunch of other states
were like dude we're out
so if in one of these red states that
has specifically issued a mandate like a
law or an executive order or whatever
saying you cannot mandate masks and then
there is a federal building saying we
will kick you out unless you wear a mask
can the state then go to the federal
government say get out you're in
violation of our laws and I know that's
not as serious as soldiers occupying the
base I'm just saying like their the
potential for a clash between states and
the federal government exists that could
be a single grain of sand that adds to
the Heap over time
but I genuinely find that interesting
especially when West Virginia has no
mask mandate but these Federal buildings
do have one I don't think West Virginia
banned stores from having masks and I
don't think Florida did that either it's
just kind of a hypothetical if we move
into vaccine mandate territory if Joe
Biden says that anybody who wants to go
into a federal building has to have
proof of vaccination then you get into
crazy territory with Texas and Florida
South Dakota or whatever where we could
potentially see States say now we
actually want to secede or we might get
an original jurisdiction claim which
would would be like what happened in the
election with all the states going
straight to the Supreme Court and
challenging the federal government's
Authority
that would be so it's so interesting
because
we haven't seen any actual clashes
right I mean you know those videos are
coming what do you mean when you mean
classroom between like federal and state
no I'm in between people right between
like we saw the guys show we saw the
people shouting at each other wasn't
there a nurse who just got fired and
there there have been a lot of yeah
their security was having trying to have
her leave there have been a lot of
clashes
there's there's a video right now of a
guy harassing him in a Target oh he's
wearing a pin that says I'm vaccinated
and she's like leave me alone he's like
no and he's following around and
Security's stopping him there's one
video of a guy stalking a woman and he
goes is anybody else mad that we have to
wear a mask and she doesn't
um that's the thing too it's like once
you've accepted the The Tyranny upon
yourself and then you really need to
enforce it on others just to make sure
that you're not the fool right and
that's that's kind of a problem we have
that going on I was uh so I was uh I saw
this post from this guy Theater Company
situation in San Francisco and this guy
was complaining that he had gone to a
theater performance and there were
people who took their masks off once the
lights went down and he complained to
literally everybody and he started
saying he wrote this whole post about it
and it was uh he was saying that um
these people not masking ruins the
experience for everybody else and he
complained to the theater company and
the ushers and the patrons themselves
and literally everyone and he took it
online not even realizing that he's the
one who's ruining this he can't just
Live and Let Live if he wants to you
know wear a mask or a tie or a belt
whatever that's his issue in that video
you brought up where it's the black
family and he's like yo it's a
segregation he yells out something like
is this the country you want to live in
and someone yells yes yeah people were
like yes like they like the boot it's
horrible it's just and it's it's
terrifying to watch this happen and to
watch civilians that's the thing that I
find so horrifying about it is the way
that the enforcement works so in New
York City this vaccine mandate thing
it's there's no cops doing it there's
you know maybe the random health
inspector is going to show up and you're
gonna have situations where you know
somebody accidentally it gets let in and
it's like the you know serving people
without proper ID situation or whatever
but that's what we're looking at so I've
talked to a bunch of people about it and
they say they don't know how to push
back against it because it's just
pushing back against somebody else who
is being pushed by the same rules I I do
not accept that I don't know yeah well
it's it's what people are looking at
they don't know they don't know how to
deal with it people do you show up at
Starbucks that's making you wear a mask
with your with your gun like what do you
do no you just don't use your mask you
don't wear a mask you don't show your
vaccine card and the person says at the
restaurant okay then you can't come in
and you do so what do you do you know
just walk away you just don't so it
leads also to people self-segregating
themselves out of society
I think that when someone when someone
says oh but I'm being forced to do it
too it's like no you're not no you're
not you're not being forced to do it
you're just choosing to do it because
you don't want you don't want to deal
with you don't you don't want to be
responsible or you don't want to lose
your job I just don't think they'd lose
their job either
so the person at the restaurant says
show me your vaccine card and show me
your ID and you say no and they say I'm
not going to let you in what do you do
do you just walk past them and sit down
you don't go there don't give money to
businesses that are willing to enforce
it I get it yeah but how do you even
know which ones are going to enforce it
until you show up they're all going to
say yes uh they're so I called 25 one of
them said no okay one of them was like I
don't know uh no I think that's fine not
maybe they just didn't realize what was
going on because they didn't pay
attention that's possible but but uh
go there and you know here's what you do
it's really really simple you go to your
bank you take out as much money as you
can in cash then you walk you you get
you put on a stove pipe pad or whatever
and a tuxedo and you walk up twirling a
cane and and knock on the door and you
walk in and you've got all the cash in
your hand and you're flipping it around
and when they're alive do you have a Vex
card oh oh no I don't but look at all
this money I was gonna spend and then
when they kick you'll go I guess you
don't want money I'm kidding don't
actually do that they they don't though
they don't want you no they they do
there was a bunch of restaurants that
had been complaining there was a story
where a journalist went around asking
they said revenues are down 25 and they
can't handle this it's destroying their
businesses and I'm just like if you
still live in New York after literally
everything you've seen I'm gonna put my
feet back grab a drink and just laugh
yeah well I mean there's basically it's
in New York like
it's sort of you know I how about don't
how about don't but I mean we have real
world data now that psychologists are
going to have an absolute field day with
because this is like what you know all
of the classic studies on obedience were
based around and now there's just data
everywhere in in real world information
that there's going to be crazy studies
that happen based on all of all these
events we live in a simulation we've
destroyed our entire social sciences no
no we live in a simulation and this is
the purpose to see how many people would
just be like you hit me harder Daddy to
gather data for the simulator but we
already saw that that was like the whole
first half of the 20th century oh yeah I
know we said Hit Me Harder daddy until I
bleed please but maybe we did maybe
maybe the test is with the history
knowing this
can you know what happens to a
population with a history of negative
consequences to authoritarianism what
happens when you then reintroduce
authoritarianism to a population that
knows it and we can clearly see I I
that's why I call it a cult you know
these are people who just believe
whatever they hear on TV and it's like
lies all the time they say like I trust
the science it's like you didn't even
read it they're like doing they
criticize people who do research like
all you did was read a few articles did
you do a double-blind controlled study
and it's like no and you didn't even
read the articles it's like you've done
less than I have
thanks for checking out this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time